is food about taste is it about
fulfilling hunger it about basic needs
No on to the next burner the Pearson me
loves burgers meat cheese bun excellent
but I'm not gonna lie I have a soft spot
for stunt burgers the crazy stuff you
see on social media the spectacle the
kind of dough chefs live to break rules
and I can't think of a better person to
do that with than my boy Ilan Hall
Top Chef alum and knife fight guru
tonight we're here to stretch the
definition of what a burger can be it's
an epic face off and we're gonna let an
all-star panel of judges tell us if
we've gone too far Alvin when you're
looking at Instagram how do you react to
Sun burgers like these crazy giant piled
high burgers that's it's it I'm not
gonna lie to you it's tough for me man
I'm more of like a meat cheese bun kind
of guy you know maybe a pickle I do like
how it pushes your creativity so
scrolling through my feet and I see
these stunt burgers and I'm like the
chef in me just says lucky I could do
better you know the insecure monster
inside of me says the same thing it's
kind of like one of those things when
you're a kid and you just mix different
household products together yeah your
potion having like your creativity and
just even if it doesn't work in its
complete failure you're still wanting to
create something yo like let's throw it
down let's do some stunts burgers to see
who could come up with what I mean to be
tough for me I've got ideas already cuz
I know you're your Top Chef alum
knife-fight master I'm gonna crush you
man
yeah you probably will so I'm calling
this a baseball burger okay starts off
with a thinly sliced onions I have a
hard time eating baseball's so how are
them how is that it doesn't matter
there's a Sun burger man like it's gonna
be great you know cut in half you're
gonna be like whoa this is [ __ ]
amazing
wait so why that's why is it called the
baseball burgers how many more round the
onions that I'm gonna smash into it I'm
gonna make it look like you know like
the little thread Oh like the stitching
around a base yeah yeah that's cool you
got my patties I'm stuffing it with
American cheese that's a big thing with
snot burgers having his stuff you're
wrapping it like a baseball yeah so yeah
basically and butter just getting that
like nice carmelization on so it's equal
parts for weight burger and butter yeah
we're pretty much fortifying the beef
and butter yeah I feel like this is kind
of like the secret to this grilled
cheese top and bottom you're taking two
sort of beloved concepts and mashing
them together I mean I might want to
kill myself after I eat it but I get it
cheese on the burger - yes sir
fucking-a what's next is my Southern
California Flair right Thousand Island
dressing okay perfect that's it that's
it that's the burn no vegetables except
for the hands not the onions
all right that's a salad voila this is
my stun burger baseball burger it looks
great but I'm gonna I'm gonna crush you
I got to see this Top Chef [ __ ] Lyle I'm
gonna shower to show you this nice real
time
all right cool we're done let's go I'm
taking a few things that I love I love
hamburgers
I love poutine and I love Bonnie
sandwiches right so I'm gonna make it
all into one and I'm gonna make a bond
me poutine burger just so much buzz
words man it's too it's too much too
many buzzer - tags so this is like a
French French roll right okay
so Patti I'm just gonna season it with a
little bit of salt and I made a little
spice mix I use this one I'm doing meat
when I'm doing burgers a little bit of
fuzz porcini powder nutritional yeast
smoked paprika quick-like things that
taste delicious in there that's how
you're gonna put cracking okay it's a
little bit of oil in this nice hot
griddle and I like my burgers to be a
little bit rare so I want to get that
super nice crust that's why I want to
really
hot griddle I also have some pork that I
cooked overnight that I braised and
pulled with a little bit of this and a
little bit of seasoning seasoning so
it's all I'm gonna use a little bit of
that meat now I've got my fries all
right because I feel like what every
burger you need fry is cheating it's
cheating because I made her come on I
made them it's a burger competition but
these are going on the burger I'm gonna
get them super crunchy because they're
gonna be covered in a lot of wet stuff
got my fries and I'm gonna load them up
and make my little sort of mini poutine
uh-huh and this ultimately is gonna
slide on top of the burger got a little
bit of my cheese bird and got a little
bit of duck liver pate got our meat bun
conte burger fries cheese curds gravy go
a little bit of pickles how many [ __ ]
ingredients let's see cucumber slightly
spicy a little bit mildly terre pickles
or really really spice got QP need some
more fat sriracha
sriracha now we're going cilantro a lot
of cilantro a lot of pickles which is so
fatty gotta hide the flavor of the
burger
that's why jalapenos so you're getting
spice from multiple angles
and that it's a [ __ ] Bonnie
poutine burger you're forgetting
something
what am I forgetting your ribs oh [ __ ]
there's so much [ __ ] in this that he
forgot the ribs there we go all right
that's AB on me poutine burger so here
we are your creation he my creation well
we gotta get some of the heavy hitters
to check out what we've done we have
miss info okay food girls yeah we got
Sean Evans from hot ones awesome and we
have Matty Matty Matty Matheson
supper-table Abe I love you and I
respect you yo but I [ __ ] schooled you
on this burger
may the best burger will yes I agree mom
man
hello everybody hello hello what so this
is a mash-up of a couple things that I
love and some things we serve at the
restaurant so we used to a bonhomie
poutine where we would do the basic
setup of a poutine but use flavors of
traditional roast pork confit sandwich
and so I took that a step further and
put that all on top of burger before we
take a bite it's worth acknowledging you
know this is like the burger American
Idol you know this is the top chefs
answer but an internet version and if
Maddie's Tom and if miss info is Padma
then I'm Judge Judy okay so we're going
no-holds-barred it's the real real fake
should be I think miss info would be
more like Gail Simmons I hope you all
enjoy but I can't bear to watch you eat
I'm so nervous
thank you very much for the burger enjoy
guys
you guys submissions yeah exactly
otherwise unhinge my jaw I don't know if
this is a 20,000 like Instagram picture
no this is the 20,000 mics at all this
is like 3k this isn't even a retweet
this is a like not even a comment I
don't think it's stunty enough I think
it's kind of he's just making a
cheeseburger in a different sandwich
it's [ __ ] delicious but that's not
why we're here okay so what is the
formula for the hundred K likes novel
color and like if it was gonna be
poutine then the bun would be made of
poutine right like it would be a bond
made out of fries and cheese yeah no
bread or like a ramen bun or something
this is what you have to do it yeah this
sandwich is not a big
eat a ramen [ __ ] burger right people
are crazy you gotta make it like you
hate it you have to make something so
ridiculous that you look at it you're
like that's [ __ ] ridiculous
right yep but stupid unedible all of a
sudden you got 10 million hits delicious
sandwich not offensive enough yeah it's
just done right just done on to the next
burger bring the meats dinner and my
buns
cheese buns I see okay so I'm a burger
purus I just like meat cheese and bread
it's a stunt
I did a baseball burger this is as
outrageous as I get cut it in half
watch it moves out enjoy thank you thank
you thank you
I mean she's right away I think you know
I go I go straight for it cuz this is he
kind of nailed this stupid is visual it
is a thing yeah he does kind of like
past that original task is like right
when it was so we didn't even know what
kind of burgers were coming out and I
wanted to take a picture of it watch
this okay
oh my god mine made a noise oh my god
oh it's like animated there's something
getting out of it this is nuts
look at that this is nuts it's going
it's erupting like jizz on your plate no
jizz talk you can't have just talked I
think I'm the only one here who can you
can have dress talk I can't talk about
the Jews Shaun definitely can't talk
about the Jews see this is a perfect
example does it taste
good I like the other burger better yeah
I don't like it butters
I hate perfect example a [ __ ]
Instagram food two bites and you're out
I feel kind of gross oh I feel a little
gross here's what I'm the empty spot
this is the anti spa I am a junkyard
goat when it comes to food you're
disgusting
I enjoyed it into it I kind of want them
to package this up and I'll take it home
like I'm out of this I'm into the
meatball baseball grilled cheese onion
burger it's like cheese on cheese on
cheese on cheese with a side of dry beef
what a dish
miss info doesn't [ __ ] around am I gonna
get more followers off of this yes yes
yeah 100%
yeah this is the Instagram burger it
ends up on the popular page this is our
face the feed goes crazy you got a DM
from a girl you didn't talk to you for
three years oh my god where'd you get
that
lick lick lick lick we've had the
burgers we've talked them out I think
it's time to let the chef's know which
one is wearing the crown tonight bring
out the chefs
[Music]
alright guys first I want to say thank
you for dinner I was starving when I got
here and now I feel full I feel good so
thank you for that Ilana I came to your
burger it was just straight A's across
the board when it came to taste
everybody here at the table
loves your burger thank you where it
lost some points where we were like is
this the Klout rocket-ship that I need
to just start stacking likes and getting
those DMS that I need so so so so bad
and that was where it kind of fell short
for us but on taste everybody loved it
Alvin I loved it I'm into it let's make
it a menu item okay I'll be in here for
breakfast every single day down the
table at lost some points in that
department not from me though hell but
not for me buddy
but we're all in agreement that when
your burger was plopped down in front of
us
me and Maddie we were quick on the draw
with the phone we immediately took
pictures when we huddled up we decided
what's gonna get us 20,000 likes and it
was the potato bun grilled cheese
baseball burger that was gonna get us
there so Alvin you are the winner whoo
the emotion it is know what it is last
time I lose something yes
[Music]
got cut loose she got cut loose thank
you yes